for entry into and what one what do you
want excited about I guess its premiere
night I'm like so it's weird right I
don't know if we're going to be the same
no not scary well FaceTime separated by
coasts Oh it'll be different times Ruth
oh no yikes
yeah I'll spoiler princes yeah I know
what it is um they just give me my lions
I don't know yes um yeah I guess like
when the show is going there's this
conversation happening with the audience
like on social media that isn't
happening when we're the rest of the
year I'm just excited to sort of like
see you guys again it's not a little
it's like cyber and a false reality that
we're all living in but I'm excited to
keep in that reality well I mean we
started writing this season what like
May oh my god first week of May to Mays
ago yeah you're gonna have to go and so
to get to finally put it out and mangas
you know just to have it out in the
world these are our little babies and
then they get to go off to college when
we put them on
what are you must expect I think they're
I believe yeah oh no or you know what
I'm sorry can I say can I curse oh you
guys would say yeah but there's like one
dude in the back defense yeah I was
going to say Ivy League because
that doesn't matter
they all they all the little babies are
like going to art school and liberal
arts colleges if you like me pay a lot
of money not to go to it yeah go to NYU
you can pay I get expresses and get a
nun I believe not quite I believe
education what are you most excited
about I mean it's airing is a crazy time
it's like my heart is racing for an hour
leading up to it and then it's like I
help you I mean this was big we should
we showed this episode of a cluster fest
which is in San Francisco a couple
months ago and I gotta say this episode
I think I might be most excited for this
episode to air but
but there's a bunch that are I mean like
there's an episode where we eat
mushrooms which is going to blow your
mind
I it's so special and I'm saying that
not just because of us involved but
mostly because of Mike Harry who does
all the title sequences the animated
teach sequences Mike collaborated so
hard with us on this episode and it's
gonna you're gonna go net I was grossing
a be out before by saying
dice dice for the word diaper but you
guys know we want to wear this when you
watch the show because I'm literally
like you know 1 out of 20 times that I
laugh I pee a little
and I'm just like just 1 out of 20
that's like that's hot too much I know
too much I'm I'm trying to do kegels in
the shower but I'm just like you just
want to protect your couch it's it's
really I'm really proud of this and
season yeah so uh we shall move to the
audience Q&A because what the what's bug
we're talking about here yeah listening
is you guys you might have some
questions I'm gonna lose more of you
part of that walk don't run all right
while you're like still getting there
should we should we start I think I have
terrible eyesight don't wear contacts
it's a fun game I play with myself but
this first person it really fun and
she's right oh great and there's
literally screen sets that I can see but
great shirt you ran abroad City
lovin did you cut that yourself did you
cut the sleeves yourself it's really
good I can't do it fits really well I
think if I didn't have to show it out
the best part they'd fit better but that
looks so good cute ok mouth closer to
the mic yeah better yep perfect
your name's ever been only thank you for
making come Queen a thing now and then
first of all secondly when you guys have
that episode with RuPaul what wisdom did
he give you fool
oh my goodness okay first thing is
he gave us the wisdom of dirty charades
this is a game that is okay charades is
pretty hard but dirty charades is harder
you make something normal something
normal that you would normally do in
shirase you make it slightly dirty like
the Lion King
you're like the Lions dung or whatever
and then you're doing this to raids for
this dirty thing you know one off of a
normal thing that was not his wife I
mean he's got more with him than that
but that was honestly like now I'm
trying to end up with either one it was
like um that was huge for me it's like
actually made me interested in change I
am terrible at it I'm like trying to
come up with a good a really good one of
wisdom
no of the charades though it's really
hard he's so good in it if I cared he
had a good one for terms of endearment
like terms of income men or something I
don't know if that's right it was better
yes but anyway I felt like he's in a
couple episodes actually which is
exciting he's not just in one and I am
NOT in a lot of scenes with him but so I
got to just sort of interact with him
just like us off screen and I don't know
if I've met anyone that is that when you
meet them just hanging out there they
just by being who he is he teaches you
to be exactly who you are we were saying
that he like made broad city possible by
being RuPaul you know we all grew up
watching
RuPaul on TV whenever he was on I mean
it was it was like just the richest
osmosis I just want to like rub on and
to get some of his whatever his like
business much as like again but that's
it thanks thanks
hi my name is grace okay good
um I was wondering if you guys could
give us like the background behind the
vowel character like how you guys came
up with her
well how we came up with her was in
college I when I first started drinking
or in college when I was drinking
college I would drink Southern Comfort
which is disgusting disgusting there was
that song so cool and yeah me and my
friend Mike would would drink and I
would this is so what ever I would black
out basically and he would be like valve
coming up tonight and it was legit Val
Val on the show is way more fun than Val
in real life Val in real life would like
I would like I got remember I got a
fight with a friend of mine who is
staying at my apartment we were in like
the front hall she was saying she's like
Eden from out of town staying with me we
had gone out and we're in the lobby of
we were inside my front door and I am
like I do and she reenacted this for me
and I say I was like I do not live here
I don't know what you're saying you're
not you don't live in this city man I
don't live here why are we in it she's
like this is your key we're in the
building you live upstairs
you got a staff and so that was my real
Val fun Val things yeah I'm like bring
around yeah thank you yeah how's it
going I'm like freaking out I forgot
what I was going to say D thank you
okay no you remember it and remember ah
Mike you might go to episode is
apartment hunters it's the best
never how is it working with Amy Sedaris
oh my god it was such first of all give
it up for a Miss Dara she's escaping new
show coming out I can't wait around
production yeah that's right on truTV
so check it out Amy Sedaris is like at
least 15 Jerri Blank is like 15%
applying facial expressions like at all
times so thanks thank her I thank her
for a part of my face and it was so much
fun she is a true clown living her
comedy always making joke she brought
the neck brace with the pins on it
already like I thought this might be
good I mean she's unbelievable
she's like brought this sock but she was
like I really I really love it with
stuff her southern accent is delicious
it is like I'm just like mean I love it
I just want that southern accent never
driving getting a doughnut we got
doughnuts on sentences shushies like
choking on him was Alaska a bit you nut
she is so funny she's whispering stuff
or she walks by she she's a dream we
drove around in that smart car and in
the middle she goes I don't even have my
license Cuban oh go for it I go in with
your door just the thing of um I got
bitches down on my Susie was all her we
were like it was she's like they stink
we were like ah hilarious my favorite is
you can fit a king-size bed in there
yeah if you fold it up like a taco oh my
god she was one of the hardest to act
opposite because it's very hard to be a
straight man to someone like that yeah
oh so funny hey girl my name is Becca I
need a gun for being absolute Queens so
much to me that guy oh so sweet you've
had such amazing guest stars on the show
and I can't wait for the ones to come so
is your each of your dream guest starred
real or fantasy Dead or Alive
anything goes you know whole
dream a dead dream be Arthur
can you imagine be our third Nana taking
the girl can you imagine just heard
oh wow
not thinking were funny I wish I wish a
for Lucille Ball I even just
thinking of that but like old wrinkly
Lucille Ball like you know that
Hollywood has rejected her Lucille Ball
ah incredible I mean those are my dead
ones I mean I did whatever you want
continue it um probably rather Robin
Williams uh oh man that would be
incredible sorry but you know it would
be funny Stevie Wonder you ever anybody
ever I went to his concert and he was so
funny
and the man has more blind jokes than
I've ever heard anyone now he's like
can't read the cue cards he's like make
it look like jokes left and right he's
just caracal that would be funny for him
to be like a confident oh good question
thanks thanks ed Rebecca how can I eat
get home safe watch it drinks okay hey
girl you can wear the towel down yeah I
bet excluding my dye food yeah hey my
question was whether it's from this
season the next season or a previous
season or was a joke or a punchline you
couldn't get through because it's just
too funny oh my god
could we give it's so hard to explain
you know what because they're gonna even
forget I think by the time an item so
you won't even understand don't even
make sense the context is crazy just
look out over the ten episodes for I was
the horse and then stay through stick
with
it I mean ever female orgasm stick with
it to the credit bed because then you'll
see we don't we don't do like bloopers
for our credit beds but this one we were
like we don't crack like this normally
and it was like four or five in the
morning and it was so fun
and we were like ah it was just so funny
like cbtos like it was still the credit
bed that's a term I don't think I maybe
you guys know every term so it's a
second there's a second montage of women
that was just on the tail end of the
episode we're the credits roll real fast
that's the credit bed and often times
when it shows on TV
they'll run an advertisement there but
when you watch it on iTunes or if you
think we run show the credit bag rerun
you'll get to see it's 15 seconds of a
little extra thing we put in and we'll
put on Instagram we put the credit feds
actually answer in for 15 seconds and we
never put bloopers bloopers are always
just like extra content and the old
written it's like I had to learn because
we're like looking at like fun we're
having it's so funny we've got we died
and we end we kept trying to do it again
like we would break and we would be like
no no no guys we got this we can do this
everybody would break I can't go home we
have to drive to Westchester after that
you know it's like get us and we were
like sorry sorry it it is so funny and
the joke itself is not brilliant look at
that what you're when you see your who
like this is what they is that laughing
it but if you actually watch the credit
bed and then go back and watch the
episode you can see me really almost
break in the scene it's cute it's so
hard yeah
so a good question could we're usually
like yeah now but this one we like we
have it yeah the headers this for me
we have time for one more question we'll
see on Twitter we'll see on Instagram hi
hi Ruby I see you see the injured female
girl love it my t-shirt yeah so she
literally just took my questions I want
to improvise right now super fan I love
Monica and just getting an ammonia in
her sister yeah okay so do you ever see
Alana acting on Abby's crush her crush
for Adam her crush for Abby and also
because I'm a big believer of no mo FOMO
oh wait so happen oh there you go
because you're believer in no mo FOMO no
mo FOMO my friends and I Oh your friends
elio then suring you your friend thing
what's happening your friends are you
going to ask an inappropriate question
no no your friends and you what even
just shout it what's going on Oh cute
but isn't one ever gonna act under crush
I don't know I think we want to like
keep it open ended you know it's very
open situation and we've talked about
like a way to whatever I like a next
beat of it or I don't know I'm not sure
what I'm not sure how we're going to do
we've talked about a lot of different
versions but it's really just like a
friendship at heart and like you know
when you hook up even when you hook up
with a friend and you're like uh there's
my friend and it's not any different
kind of like even if they did they would
still just be the same friends but I
don't maybe else a lot of them finally
hooks up with a being and I was just
like terrible and Ben and she's like
whoa yeah that wouldn't be in that would
not be pulling from my real life and now
now I didn't happen she was
not that we didn't you know it's not uh
something me mmm experiments with who
would dub with the Q&A portion
[Music]